こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
えー
[音楽]
うーん
そうだなまあ動画のタイトルにある通り
です
やめてくれもうやめてくれるとしか言え
ないですけどもなんか
久々に
うわ
うぜーってなったことがありましたうぜえ
というかなんか普通に
嫌だなというかこれいやー
逆の立場だったらどう思いますかっていう
ことがあったので
[音楽]
あんまりその
さらすとかそういうことはしたくないん
ですけど
あ今工事してますはいえはい今ごめん家を
ね絶賛ええと3軒の家を4件のうちに
調べるんでちょっと今工事してるのでお
楽しみにそういう話じゃないんです今回人
に話じゃないんです今回僕がしたいのは
そういう話じゃない割と怒ってます
バチバチに怒ってますえっとこれいつの話
かっていうと本当に3日前ぐらいかな最近
あった話でその時俺あの
テレビの収録で千葉にいて何があったか
直接見てないんですけれどもちょっと後輩
がそれを目撃したらしくてちょっと話を
聞いてみようと思います
どうもこんにちは
静岡が産んだ令和の諸葛孔明イケメンです
よろしくお願いしますお願いします
諸葛孔明って何ですかあのほらあった
じゃん最近あの事件ありましたね
めっちゃ笑顔だなおじさんで笑えなかった
けど
普通にいや俺も見た時は笑わなかったっす
よ
ふざけてる止まれるじゃん確かに何を見た
の何を見たかっていうと
簡単に言うと
多分盗撮ってやつですね
僕はですねあのはじめさんちの家の
駐車場に待機してたんですけどまあ待機し
ててちょっとコンビニこうかなって思った
時にバックミラーみたいな車が止まってて
後ろにでなんか最初第1さんっぽい車だっ
たんでずっと見てたんですよ
でちょっと挨拶しようかなと思ってバック
ミラー見てたら
家族が
ワイワイと出てきてで後ろ見てたら
ワンチャンこれあるかなと思ったら
あの
急に家の前はじめさんち家の前5つで
ワンチャンこれあるからって何なんかその
迷惑行為すんのかなみたいななんかとか来
たなっていうなんかいや絶対狙ってきたな
と思って見てたら
案の定
子供としかもその親がお母さんがその
始めさんちの家の前でと写真を撮ってた
なるほどなるほどパッと見ただけですけど
ムカつきました俺ね
ムカついたムカついたっすね
話を聞いたっていう
感じですていうちょっとたまたま後輩が
なんかちょっと
ヘラヘラしてたんですけども
割と
捨てたなと思って話を聞く限り結構すごい
んですよね一応僕の家も全方向監視カメラ
ついてるんで僕の家の周りで何かしたら
もうすぐ分かりますよって
散々
言ってきたと思うんですよいろんな動画で
それでもなおするかっていう感じの行動し
てたので
すいませんなんかその行為の許しちゃうと
同じことどうする人たくさん出てきちゃっ
て本当に
俺泥棒というより近所の人の迷惑がかかっ
てしまうのでなんかほんと見せるものでは
ないと思うんですけどもうどこの誰かも
わかんないからちょっと自覚も持って
もらいたいなと思ってちょっと映像見たい
と思います監視カメラのはいこれがえっと
僕の家の前の映像になります
左側にあるこの車が広範囲の
目撃者の装備の車で
まあここがあの
僕の家の車が駐車できるスペースとなって
ますでこの監視カメラの後ろ側に俺の家が
あるっていう感じになってますまあ正直
これだけお家めっちゃでかいんですよ近所
から見てももうどのお家よりも大きいので
それも隠し通せないからさもう本当なんか
興味本位で切っちゃったりなんか一目見に
来たりとかさそれは俺はもう正直仕方ない
と思ってる仕方ないと思ってるけどもなん
かその
撮影とかさ記念撮影とかは
普通に考えて嫌じゃないって思う
飽きましたね話していただきましたねはい
この車です
全部取れてるからねあこれでサーベがなん
か
コンビニ行こうって言ってたのかなこの
タイミングではい見てくださいもう
降りてきてますね家族が
男の子と
これはお母さんかな
運転席からお父さんも出てきてます
はい子供が
道路のど真ん中でピースしてお父さんと
お母さんが写真を撮ってます
めちゃくちゃ決めポーズかなり足を開いて
ます
いやーいい写真撮れたんだろうなあいい
写真撮れてるよこの家族からしたらきっと
すごい楽しい思い出になってるんでしょう
けど
俺からするとすごい嫌な思い出になってる
よでこれで
本当にキャップ痩せてよ
許せんけどね子供だけだったらいいんです
けどこれ見て
お母さんが写真撮ってんすよお母さんが
写真撮られてるこれ
子供にカメラ持たせてさ息子に息子に
カメラも出せてお母様がもう
取って私っていう感じでやってて
これね
お母さんまで取っちゃうかなっていうで次
は持つにお父さんが
堂々と水の真ん中に来て
お父さんちょっと近くない
うちの敷地内よ
[音楽]
これまさか
息子と撮ってるtiktok撮ってるね
これこの動きtiktok撮ってるね家の
前で
完全にダンスしてたよ今これ絶対動画撮っ
てたね何かしら
まだかと言わんばかりのまだ
子供が来て
撮る
振りすぎだよあとその車そこ止めちゃ迷惑
でしょ普通に
ほら他の方普通にいらっしゃるしこういう
近所の方がさこういうの見てどう思うのっ
てなんか俺じゃん悪いのそれはいでもう
なんか
取るだけ取って装束したとバックして
帰っていきましたとはいという感じの
出来事がありましたあの本当にこの家に
住んでこんな目立つ絵に住んでてあれなん
ですけどもうさバレてるのは
仕方ないです
外にとってる俺も悪いしそんな目立つ家に
住んでる僕も悪いんですけどだからなんか
さその通っちゃってたまたま見かけてああ
初めの家だとかこれが東京にいないかは
すごいとかそれはもう仕方ないことだと
思うんですけどもどんな人の家を無断で
取るなら
勝手に取るのだけはやめてくれ
本当に逆のことしますよじゃあ僕あなた達
にあなたたちのお家の目の前に行って
じゃあ俺めちゃくちゃ決めポーズして
tiktok撮ってもいいんですかって
いう話になりますよ嫌でしょ俺も嫌だった
俺も嫌だったけど
もうねそこはもう
常識の話になってくるのであなたたちの
家族にそういう
住んでる人の気持ちが分かるかどうかって
いう話になってくるかなと思いますあとさ
俺はこの
映像を見てこの好意を見て思ったのがあの
ね
子供は嬉しかったんでしょ嬉しかったと
思うよ多分なんですけどこの人たち近所の
人じゃないと思うんですよ近所の人たちも
そんな水抜けるらしいからないんで俺の家
とか見ても記念撮影とかしないんで多分
土日とかで遠くから来たのかなわかんない
けどそういうタイミングで始める社長の
うちこれで記念写真撮ったのかなと思うん
ですけどそうやって憧れてというかさ
はじめしゃちょーの初めの鬱だって言って
喜んでくれるのはすごい嬉しいんですけど
写真撮りたくなる気持ちもすごく分かる俺
だってそうすると思う
それを止めるのは親の仕事だと思います
ごめん
俺は別に
親でもないし結婚もしてないし子供もい
ないから偉そうなことはいないけど俺は
そうやって育ってきた悪いことしようと
悪いこと好きなんですよ
めっちゃ悪いこと好きで今もすよ悪いこと
今も悪いことしてるし子供の頃もすごい
悪いこといっぱいしてきたけどどんな時で
も絶対
親が止めて親に注意されてきました
もちろんその役割が親じゃない時もあった
学校の先生だったり親とか部活のコーチと
かいろんな大人に怒られて何人かには何と
か生きてきたんだけどそういうさ
息子の悪いとも行動を止めるのは
親であって欲しいなってなんかこれ見て
すごい思ったしなんならお母さんが写真
撮ってとかってポーズしてたからさ
誰も注意しないなと思ってその行動その子
どう育っちゃうんだろうって思ってしまい
ましたごめんほんと素直な感想を言わせて
もらうよその家の前で勝手に写真を撮っ
ちゃダメそれだけでもいいからちょっと
言ってあげて欲しかったなって思いました
だってあのお父さんお母さんみたいな
子育つわけでしょ頼むよお父さんお母さん
子供が喜んで結局あの仕方ないダメなこと
だよ俺は注意してるよ怒るけどそれを一緒
に見て写真撮ってるあのお父さんと
お母さんを見て俺は
うわマジで悪いと思ってねーなーこの人達
って思いましたはい
ごめんなさいなんかあんま許さないこと
言えないです僕は
俺はお父さんでもないから息子がいるわけ
でもないから偉そうなこと言えないけど俺
はそうやって育ってきたからマジかと誰が
あの子に善悪の判断を教えるんだと思って
はマジかーと思って見てましたはいなんか
ね
ありがとうでもそれだけなんかそれだけ愛
があってっていうか写真撮りたくなる
くらいきっと見ててくれたからもしそれを
OKってしちゃったらさそういう人たちが
たくさん家に来ちゃうじゃん
写真撮っていいってなるじゃん初めて行っ
ていいってなるじゃんそしたら俺ん家の
周り車だらけ人だらけになっちゃって
本当に近所の人たちに迷惑がかかるねそれ
だけはマジでやめてほしい頼む改めて言っ
ておきますお家には
来ないで
欲しいのと写真撮影はやめてください
ごめんなさい
取られたら俺も取るから心からやめて
ほしいと思ってます
[音楽]
俺じゃあ
久々になんかえぐいも見ましたねなんか
子供の悪ふざけじゃないなっていう感じあ
であの今回の件なんですけれどもちょっと
あのなんかとある方がですねどうしても
あのこの映像を見て言いたいことがあった
みたいなのでちょっと最後その方とのお話
でこの動画を終わりたいと思いますでは
お母さん
ダメだっていくつだよお母さんいいよ
お母さんも食べたよなぁ
秩序がなくなってしまう気がするんだよね
一人がやり始めてじゃあOKって言っ
ちゃったらもう無限
[音楽]